[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي انه اصدر اوامر لاتخاذ خطوات
فوريه في اعقاب الهجمات الارهابيه على حد
تعبيره واعلن جالنت في تغريده ان الجيش
سيدعم وحدات الشرطه حيثما كان الامر
ضروريا مضيفا ان اغلاق المعابر مع الضفه
الغربيه وغزه سيستمر حتى نهايه عيد الفصح
وامر باستدعاء اربع سرايا احتياط من حرس
الحدود
قال البنتاجون ان وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
اكد خلال اتصال مع نظير الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل وحثها على عدم اتخاذ اجراءات
تفاقم التوتر من جهاتها قالت وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه ان الوزيره
الامريكي على ما وصفته بالهجمات الارهابيه
على اسرائيل مؤخرا التي شملت اطلاق صواريخ
وقذائف صاروخيه من غزه ولبنان
اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان ثلاث قذائف اطلقت
من الاراضي السوريه سقطت منها اثنتان في
منطقه مفتوحه بالجولان السوري المحتل
وواحده عند خط وقف اطلاق النار وهذه المره
الثانيه خلال خمس ساعات حيث كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد اكد مساء السبت اطلاق ثلاث
قذائف من الاراضي السوريه سقطت واحده في
منطقه مفتوحه داخل الاراضي الاردنيه
وواحده في الجولان والثالثه داخل الاراضي
السوريه وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف
منطقه في سوريا انطلقت منها الصواريخ نحو
اسرائيل
فتحت الاداره الامريكيه تحقيقا في تسريب
وثائق سريه لوزاره الدفاع تتضمن تفاصيل عن
القدرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه والدعم
الغربي واسرار خاصه بالامن القومي
الامريكي تتعلق بالشرق الاوسط والصين ونقل
الصحيفه
قولهم ان البيت الابيض قلق بشان تداعيات
التسريب وانه يتم حاليا دراسه مجموعه من
الاحتمالات بشان كيفيه حدوث الاختراق ورجح
المسؤولون ان يكون للتسريب تاثير على
الامن القومي للولايات المتحده في جميع
انحاء العالم
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه انها ارسلت الى
الشرق الاوسط الغواصه التي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه والمزوده بصواريخ موجهه لدعم
الاسطول الخامس الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقرا
له وقال الترمذي المتحدث باسم البحريه ان
الغواصه قادره على حمل ما يصل الى 154
صاروخ كروز من طراز توماهوك مضيفا انها
ارسلت للمساعده في نشر الامن البحري في
المنطقه ونقل الصحيفه
ان الاداره الامريكيه تلقت معلومات تفيد
بان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات في المنطقه
قريبا
اعلن الجيش الصيني بدا مناورات عسكريه
لمده ثلاثه ايام في مضيق تايوان تشمل
تدريبا على تطويق الجزيره وقال في بيان ان
المناورات تعد تحذيرا جديا لمن وصفهم
بالانفصاليين التايوانيين بسبب ما وصفه
بتواطؤهم مع قوى خارجيه ياتي الاعلان عن
بدء المناورات عقب عوده رئيس التايوان من
زياره للولايات المتحده خلالها رئيس مجلس
النواب كاظم ماكارتي وادانت وزاره
الخارجيه التايوانيه المناورات الصينيه
وقالت انها تهدد الاستقرار والاملا في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء